My mom was a therapist and she saw hundreds of couples where somebody in the couple had cheated. And then the couple tried to stay together and work it out, and that's how they ended up in couples counseling. And my mom said this thing nearly always happens in this situation. This thing happens where the person who cheated confesses. Tells the spouse as many details as the spouse wants to hear, which usually is a lot. And in fact, you kind of have to tell them everything they want if there's going to be any kind of forgiveness. And so it's just all this painful detail. What happened this particular day when you said you were here and did you say I love you to the other person? Just like the incredibly painful, incredibly hard stuff. And the person who cheated says that they know they were in the wrong, and they want to work it out, and they're sorry. They're so, so sorry.
我母亲曾是一名心理治疗师，她见过数百对夫妇，其中一方曾有出轨行为。后来这些夫妇尝试重归于好，努力挽救婚姻，这就是他们最终进行婚姻咨询的原因。我母亲说，在这种情况下，几乎总是会发生一件事。出轨方会坦白，告诉配偶对方想知道的所有细节，通常细节还不少。事实上，如果想要获得某种形式的原谅，你几乎必须告诉他们想知道的一切。所以这就涉及所有那些令人痛苦的细节。比如某天你谎称在这里时到底发生了什么，你有没有对那个人说过“我爱你”？就像那些极其痛苦、极其艰难的事情。而出轨的一方会说，他们知道自己错了，他们想解决问题，他们很抱歉。他们非常、非常抱歉。
And then weeks pass, and everybody tries to get along. And at some point, the person who cheated starts to feel a little better. You know, they confessed. They cleared the air. It's a new beginning. But their spouse is living still, in a world of pain. The spouse doesn't trust them. The betrayal was so huge, the lies were so big, the spouse is still wary. And still, little bursts of anger. They're not over it.
几周过去了，大家试图相安无事。在某个时刻，出轨的一方开始感觉好一点了。你知道，他们坦白了，解开了心结，这是一个新的开始。但他们的配偶仍生活在痛苦的世界里。配偶不信任他们。背叛如此巨大，谎言如此拙劣，配偶仍然心存戒备，时不时还会爆发一阵愤怒。他们还没走出来。
And here's where it gets complicated. The person who cheated starts to get impatient. They feel like, come on, I confessed. I said I'm sorry. I've done everything I can do to make this right. But you just won't let it go. And the other person can't let it go. A very hard thing for both of them. A very hard thing for any couple to get through. And it almost always happens. The apology wasn't enough. And really, there are so many situations where apologizing doesn't do the trick, where it doesn't satisfy both parties. And not just big situations, these can be the tiniest situations in the world.
问题就变得复杂了。出轨的一方开始变得不耐烦。他们觉得，得了吧，我已经坦白了，我说了对不起，我已经尽我所能来弥补过错。但你就是不肯放过我。而另一方就是无法释怀。这对他们双方来说都是一件非常艰难的事。对任何一对夫妇来说，这都是一件非常难熬的事。而且这种情况几乎总是会发生。道歉并不足以解决问题。事实上，有太多的情况是道歉无法奏效的，无法让双方都满意。这不仅仅是指重大的情况，这些可能是世界上最微不足道的小事。
Sarah Vowell, one of our contributing editors on the radio show says that she was running late on her way to meet a friend for breakfast.
莎拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell），我们广播节目的特约编辑之一，说她在去见朋友吃早餐的路上迟到了。
I was on the subway and I realized I didn't know where breakfast was. I was, I don't know, 15 or 20 minutes late, which was just the most agonizing 15 minutes of my life of me running up and down 9th Avenue trying to remember where I was supposed to meet him. You know, I got there and he had wondered where was I was, but he brought the paper and he was fine, so I spent the entire breakfast apologizing. Then when I got home I sent him an email apologizing. Then before I went to bed I sent another apology email.
我在地铁上，突然意识到我不知道早餐约在哪里。我迟到了，大概15或20分钟，那是我生命中最煎熬的15分钟，我在第九大道上跑来跑去，拼命回忆应该在哪里见他。后来我到了，他一直在纳闷我在哪，但他带了报纸，也没生气，所以我整个早餐时间都在不停地道歉。回家后，我发了封邮件道歉。睡觉前，我又发了一封道歉邮件。
Then the next time we had breakfast I was 15 minutes early and then had to talk about how I was early this time. And it's just so stupid. And I realized at that point, the apology sickness becomes a kind of narcissism. Like, all you think about is yourself and you feel like, oh, my actions affected this other person so much I need to just constantly apologize. When really, it wasn't that big of a deal.
下一次我们吃早餐时，我提前了15分钟到，然后又不得不谈论我这次为什么提前到了。这真是太愚蠢了。在那一刻我意识到，道歉成瘾变成了一种自恋。就像你只想到你自己，你觉得，哦，我的行为对另一个人造成了这么大的影响，我需要不断地道歉。而实际上，这根本不是什么大不了的事。
This happens all the time. The apology can go wrong for either person in the transaction. Even the apologizer.
这种情况一直都在发生。道歉可能会在交易的任何一方身上出错，即使是道歉者本人。
I feel like he totally accepted my apology. It's more like I didn't accept my apology. [LAUGHTER]
我觉得他完全接受了我的道歉。更像是，我没有接受我自己的道歉。[笑声]
There's moments where you apologize to somebody and you're not doing it for selfish reasons, but because you really want them to know you're sorry. And where they really hear what you're saying and your eyes lock and everybody knows that it happened, the apology happened. Those are almost pretty rare, I think.
有些时刻，你向某人道歉并不是出于自私的原因，而是因为你真的希望他们知道你很抱歉。当他们真正听到你的话，你们四目相对，每个人都知道这发生了，道歉达成了。我认为这种情况相当罕见。
Today on our radio show, we have three stories of people groping their way toward I'm sorry, toward this moment of apology. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International, I'm Ira Glass.
今天在我们的广播节目中，我们有三个关于人们在“对不起”的道路上摸索，走向道歉时刻的故事。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》（This American Life），由国际公共广播电台（Public Radio International）发行，我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。
Our program today in three acts. And let me just say right here, it's a politics free program. Let's have a little break. Act one, "Repeat After Me." In that story, David Sedaris, his sister, and a talking bird. Act two, "Dial S for Sorry." In which we have a little visit with Mr. Apology and his wife. Act three, "Two Words You Never Want to Hear From Your Doctor." In that act, a movement to try to get people who do not like to say they're wrong to say they're wrong. Stay with us.
我们今天的节目分为三幕。先声明一下，这是一个不涉及政治的节目。让我们稍作休息。第一幕，“请跟我重复一遍”。那个故事里有大卫·塞达里斯（David Sedaris）、他的姐姐，还有一只会说话的鸟。第二幕，“拨S代表抱歉”。在那一幕中，我们将拜访“道歉先生”和他的妻子。第三幕，“医生永远不想从你口中听到的两个词”。在那一幕中，有一个运动旨在让那些不喜欢说自己错了的人承认错误。请继续收听。
Act one, "Repeat After Me."
第一幕，“请跟我重复一遍”。
This story was recorded in front of a live audience. Here's David Sedaris.
这个故事是在现场观众面前录制的。这是大卫·塞达里斯。
Although we discussed my upcoming visit to Winston-Salem, my sister and I didn't make exact arrangements until the eve of my arrival when I phoned from a hotel in Salt Lake City.
虽然我们讨论过我即将对温斯顿-塞勒姆的访问，但直到我抵达的前夕，当我从盐湖城的一家酒店打电话时，我和姐姐才做出确切的安排。
"I'll be at work when you arrive," she said. "So I'm thinking I'll just leave the key under the ower-ot near the ack door."
“你到的时候我会在上班，”她说，“所以我想我还是把钥匙留在后门旁边的花盆下面吧。”
The what?
什么？
"Ower-ot."
“花盆（ower-ot）。”
I thought she maybe had something in her mouth until I realized she was speaking in code.
我以为她嘴里含着什么东西，直到我意识到她在用暗语说话。
What are you on a speaker phone at a methadone clinic? Why can't you just tell me where you put the god damn house key?
你是在美沙酮诊所用免提通话吗？为什么你不能直接告诉我你把该死的房门钥匙放在哪儿了？
Her voice dropped to a whisper. "I just don't know that I trust these things."
她的声音压低到了耳语。“我只是不知道我是否信任这些设备。”
Are you on a cellphone?
你在用手机吗？
"Of course not," she said. "This is just a regular cordless. But still, you have to be careful."
“当然不是，”她说，“这只是普通的无绳电话。但即使这样，你还是得小心。”
My sister's the type who religiously watches the fear segments of her local eyewitness news broadcasts. Retaining nothing but the headline. She remembers that applesauce can kill you, but forgets that in order to die you have to inject it directly into your bloodstream.
我姐姐那种人，会虔诚地观看当地目击者新闻广播中的安全警示环节。除了标题之外什么都没记住。她记得苹果酱会杀死你，却忘了要死的话你得把它直接注射进血液里。
Announcements that cellphone conversations may be picked up by strangers mixed with the reported rise of both home burglaries and brain tumors, meaning that as far as she's concerned all telecommunication is potentially life threatening.
手机通话可能会被陌生人窃听的公告，混合着关于入室盗窃和脑瘤发病率上升的报道，这意味着在她看来，所有的远程通讯都有潜在的生命威胁。
OK, I said. But can you tell me which ower-ot?
好吧，我说。但你能告诉我到底是哪个花盆吗？
"It's ed." She told me. "Well, edish."
“是红色的。”她告诉我，“嗯，有点偏红。”
I arrived at Lisa's house late the following afternoon, found the key beneath the flower pot, and let myself in through the back door. A lengthy note on the coffee table explained how I might go about operating everything from the television to the waffle iron. Each carefully detailed procedure ending with the line, remember to unplug after use. The note reflected a growing hysteria. Its subtext shrieking, oh my God, he's going to be alone in my house for close to an hour.
第二天下午晚些时候我到达了丽莎的家，在花盆下面找到了钥匙，从后门进去了。咖啡桌上有一张长长的便条，解释了我该如何操作从电视到华夫饼机的所有东西。每项精心详述的操作程序结尾都是一行字：使用后记得拔掉电源。这张便条反映了一种日益增长的歇斯底里。它的潜台词在尖叫：天哪，他要一个人在我的房子里待将近一个小时。
She left her work number, her husband's work number, and the number of the next door neighbor, explaining that she didn't know the woman very well, so I probably shouldn't bother her unless it was an emergency. PPS, she's a Baptist, so don't tell her you're gay.
她留下了她的工作电话、她丈夫的工作电话，以及隔壁邻居的电话，并解释说她不太了解那个女人，所以除非是紧急情况，否则我最好不要打扰她。附言：她是浸信会教徒，所以别告诉她你是同性恋。
The last time I was alone at my sister's place, she was living in a white brick apartment complex occupied by widows and single middle-aged working women. College hadn't quite worked out the way she'd expected. And after two years in Virginia, she'd returned to Raleigh and taken a job at a wine shop. It was a normal enough life for a 21 year old, but being a dropout was now what she had planned for herself. Worse than that, it had not been planned for her.
上次我独自待在姐姐家时，她住在一个白砖公寓区，住户都是寡妇和单身中年职业女性。大学生活并没有像她预期的那样顺利。在弗吉尼亚待了两年后，她回到了罗利，在一家葡萄酒商店找了份工作。对于一个21岁的人来说，这生活算正常，但辍学并不是她为自己计划好的事情。更糟糕的是，这甚至不是别人为她计划的。
As children, we'd been assigned certain roles-- leader, bum, troublemaker, slut. Titles that effectively told us who we were. As the oldest, smartest, and bossiest, it was naturally assumed that Lisa would shoot to the top of her field, earning a master's degree in manipulation, and eventually taking over a medium-sized country. We'd always known her as an authority figure, and while we took a certain joy in watching her fall, it was disorienting to see her with so little confidence.
作为孩子，我们被分配了某些角色——领导者、游手好闲者、捣蛋鬼、荡妇。这些头衔有效地告诉了我们自己是谁。作为老大、最聪明、最霸道的人，自然认为丽莎会一路冲到她所在领域的最顶端，获得操纵学硕士学位，并最终接管一个中等规模的国家。我们一直把她当作权威人物，虽然我们看到她跌落时感到一丝幸灾乐祸，但看到她如此缺乏自信还是让人感到困惑。
Suddenly she was relying on other people's opinions, following their advice, and withering at the slightest criticism. Do you really think so? Really? She was putty.
突然间，她开始依赖别人的意见，遵循他们的建议，并在受到最轻微的批评时就萎靡不振。你真的这么认为吗？真的吗？她简直像橡皮泥一样。
My sister needed patience and understanding, but more often than not, I found myself wanting to shake her. If the oldest wasn't who she was supposed to be, then what did it mean for the rest of us?
我姐姐需要耐心和理解，但更多时候，我发现自己想摇醒她。如果老大不是她本应成为的那样，那对我们其他人来说意味着什么？
Lisa has been marked most likely to succeed and so it confused her to be ringing up gallon jugs of hardy burgundy. I had been branded as lazy and irresponsible, and so it felt right when I, too, dropped out of college.
丽莎曾被认为最有可能成功，所以看到她在给一加仑装的廉价红酒装袋，她感到困惑。我被贴上了懒惰和不负责任的标签，所以当我同样从大学退学时，我觉得很正常。
I went to live with Lisa in her white brick complex. And when I eventually left her with a broken stereo and an unpaid $80 phone bill, the general consensus was, well, what did you expect? I might reinvent myself to strangers, but to this day, as far as my family is concerned, I'm still the one most likely to set your house on fire.
我搬去和丽莎住在她那栋白砖楼里。当我最终带着一个坏掉的音响和一张80美元未付的电话费单离开她时，大家的共识是：嗯，你还指望什么呢？我可以向陌生人重塑自我，但直到今天，就我的家庭而言，我仍然是那个最有可能把你们房子烧掉的人。
While I accepted my lowered expectations, Lisa fought hard to regain her former title. The wine shop was just a temporary setback and she left shortly after becoming the manager. Photography interested her and so she taught herself to use a camera. Ultimately, landing a job in the photo department of a large international drug company where she took pictures of germs, viruses, and people reacting to germs and viruses.
虽然我接受了别人降低对我的期望，但丽莎努力争取找回她以前的头衔。那家葡萄酒商店只是暂时的挫折，她在成为经理后不久就离开了。摄影引起了她的兴趣，所以她自学了使用相机。最终，在一家大型国际制药公司的摄影部门找到了一份工作，在那里她拍摄细菌、病毒，以及人们对细菌和病毒的反应。
On weekends, for extra money, she photographed weddings, which really weren't that much of a stretch.
周末，为了赚点外快，她去拍婚礼，这其实和她的工作差不了多少。
She got married herself and then quit the drug company in order to earn an English degree. When told there was very little call for 30 page essays on Jane Austen, she got a real estate license.
她自己结了婚，然后辞去了制药公司的工作，去攻读英语学位。当被告知很少有人需要30页关于简·奥斯汀的论文时，她拿到了房地产执照。
When told the housing market was down, she returned to school to study plants. Her husband, Bob, got a new job in Winston-Salem and so they moved, buying a new three-story home in a quiet, suburban neighborhood.
当被告知房地产市场低迷时，她回到学校研究植物。她的丈夫鲍勃在温斯顿-塞勒姆得到了一份新工作，于是他们搬家了，在安静的郊区买了一栋新的三层楼房。
It was strange to think of my sister living in such a grownup place, and I was relieved to find that neither she nor Bob particularly cared for it. My sister's home didn't really lend itself to snooping and so I spent my hour in the kitchen making small talk with Henry. It was the same conversation we'd had the last time I saw him, yet still I found it fascinating. He asked how I was doing. I said I was all right.
想到我姐姐住在这个大人的地方真是奇怪，我很欣慰地发现她和鲍勃都不怎么喜欢这里。我姐姐的房子并不适合探头探脑，所以我花了一个小时在厨房里和亨利闲聊。这是我上次见他时进行的同一段对话，但我仍然觉得很有趣。他问我过得怎么样。我说我还好。
And then as if something might have drastically changed over the last few seconds, he asked again. Of all the elements of my sister's adult life, the house, the husband, the sudden interest in plants, the most unsettling is Henry. Technically, he's a Blue-fronted Amazon. But to the average layman, he's just a big parrot. The type you might see on the shoulder of a pirate.
然后，就好像过去几秒钟里可能发生了巨大的变化一样，他又问了一遍。在我姐姐成年生活的所有元素中——房子、丈夫、对植物突然产生的兴趣，最令人不安的是亨利。从技术上讲，他是一只蓝额亚马逊鹦鹉。但对外行来说，他只是一只大鹦鹉。就是你在海盗肩上可能看到的那种。
How you doing? The third time he asked, it sounded as if he really cared. I approached his cage with a detailed answer and when he lunged for the bars I screamed like a girl and ran out of the room.
你怎么样？这是他第三次问，听起来他真的很关心。我带着详细的答案走近他的笼子，当他扑向栏杆时，我像个女孩一样尖叫着跑出了房间。
"Henry likes you," sister said a short while later. She just returned from her job at the plant nursery and was sitting at the table unlacing her sneakers. "See the way he's fanning his tail, he'd never do that for Bob. Would you, Henry?"
“亨利喜欢你，”过了一会儿姐姐说。她刚从植物苗圃的工作中回来，正坐在桌边解开运动鞋的鞋带。“你看他扇动尾巴的样子，他永远不会为鲍勃那样做的。是吧，亨利？”
Bob had returned from work a few minutes earlier and immediately headed upstairs to spend time with his own bird, a balding, Green-cheeked Conure named Jose.
鲍勃几分钟前刚下班回家，直接上楼去陪他自己的鸟了，那是一只秃顶的绿颊锥尾鹦鹉，名叫何塞（Jose）。
I thought the two of them might enjoy an occasional conversation, but it turns out they can't stand one another.
我以为他们两个偶尔会喜欢交流，但结果是他们彼此都无法忍受。
"Don't even mention Jose in front of Henry," Lisa said. Bob's birds squawked from the upstairs study and the parrot responded with a series of high piercing barks. It was a trick he'd picked up from Lisa's border collie, Jessie. And what was disturbing was that he sounded exactly like a dog. Just as when speaking English, he sounded exactly like Lisa. It was creepy to hear my sister's voice coming from a beak. But I couldn't say it didn't please me.
“别在亨利面前提何塞，”丽莎说。鲍勃的鹦鹉在楼上的书房里尖叫，那只鹦鹉以一连串尖锐的高音回击。那是他从丽莎的牧羊犬杰西（Jessie）身上学到的把戏。令人不安的是，他的声音听起来简直就像一条狗。就像他讲英语时，听起来简直就像丽莎。听到我姐姐的声音从鸟喙里发出真是令人毛骨悚然。但我不能说这让我不高兴。
"Who's hungry?" she asked. "Who's hungry?" the voice repeated.
“谁饿了？”她问。“谁饿了？”那个声音重复道。
I raised my hand and she offered Henry a peanut. Taking it in his claw, his belly sagging almost to the perch, I could understand what someone might see in a parrot. Here was this strange little fat man living in my sister's kitchen. A sympathetic listener turning again and again to ask, so really, how are you?
我举起了手，她给了亨利一颗花生。他用爪子拿着它，肚子沉甸甸地几乎垂到栖木上，我能理解为什么有人会喜欢鹦鹉。这里住着一个小小的、奇怪的胖子，住在我姐姐的厨房里。一个富有同情心的倾听者，一次又一次地转过头来问：那么，真的，你过得怎么样？
I'd asked her the same question and she'd said, oh, fine. You know. She's afraid to tell me anything important knowing I'll only turn around and write about it.
我问过她同样的问题，她说，哦，挺好的。你知道的。她害怕告诉我任何重要的事情，因为她知道我只会转头就把这些写进去。
In my mind, I'm like a friendly junk man building things from the little pieces of scrap I find here and there. But my family started to see things differently. Their personal lives are the so-called pieces of scrap I so casually pick up. And they're sick of it.
在我的心目中，我就像一个友好的废品商，用我在这里那里找到的一点点废料拼凑东西。但我的家人开始以不同的眼光看待这些。他们的私人生活就是我随手捡起的那些所谓的废料。他们对此感到厌倦。
Conversations now start with the words, you have to swear you will never repeat this. I always promise, but it's generally understood that my word is no better than Henry's.
现在的谈话开始于：“你必须发誓你永远不会说出去。”我总是答应，但大家都心知肚明，我的话并不比亨利的话更有分量。
I'd gone to Winston-Salem to address the students at a local college, and then again to break some news. Sometimes when you're stoned it's fun to sit around and think of who might play you in the movie version of your life. What makes it fun is that no one is actually going to make a movie of your life. Lisa and I no longer get stoned and so it was all the harder to announce that my book had been optioned. Meaning that, in fact, someone was going to make a movie of our lives. Not a student, but a real live director people had heard of.
我去温斯顿-塞勒姆是为了给当地一所大学的学生演讲，也为了发布一些消息。有时当你嗨了的时候，坐在一起思考谁会在你的电影版生活中扮演你是件很有趣的事。有趣的地方在于，根本没人会把你的人生拍成电影。丽莎和我不嗨了，所以要宣布我的书被选定改编成电影就更难了。这意味着，事实上，有人要拍摄我们的生活电影了。不是学生，而是一个人们听说过的真正的导演。
"A what?"
“一个什么？”
I explained that he was Chinese and she asked if the movie would be in Chinese.
我解释说他是中国人，她问电影是不是中文的。
"No," I said, "he lives in America. In California. He's been here since he was a baby."
“不，”我说，“他住在美国家，在加利福尼亚。他还是个婴儿的时候就在这里了。”
"So now we have to be in a movie?" She picked her sneakers off the floor and tossed them into the laundry room. "Well," she said, "I can tell you right now that you are not dragging my bird into this."
“所以现在我们得去拍电影了？”她从地板上捡起运动鞋扔进洗衣房。“好吧，”她说，“我可以直接告诉你，你休想把我的鸟拉进去。”
Once, at a dinner party, I met a woman whose parrot had learned to imitate the automatic ice maker on her new refrigerator. "That's what happens when they're left alone," she'd said.
有一次，在晚宴上，我遇到一个女人，她的鹦鹉学会了模仿她新冰箱上的自动制冰机。“这就是独自待着时会发生的事，”她说。
It was the most depressing bit of information I'd heard in quite a while. And it stuck with me for weeks. Here was this creature born to mock its jungle neighbors and it wound up doing impressions of man-made kitchen appliances.
这是我很久以来听过的最令人沮丧的信息。它在我脑海里挥之不去了好几个星期。这是一种生来为了嘲笑丛林邻居的生物，最后却在模仿人造的厨房电器。
I repeated this story to Lisa who told me that neglect had nothing to do with it. She then prepared a cappuccino, setting the stage for Henry's pitch perfect imitation of the milk steamer.
我把这个故事讲给丽莎听，她告诉我这和忽视无关。然后她准备了一杯卡布奇诺，为亨利模仿牛奶蒸气机的那段完美表演铺路。
He can do the blender too, she said. She opened the cage door and as we sat down to our coffees, Henry glided down under onto the table. "Who wants a kiss?"
他连搅拌机也会，她说。她打开笼门，当我们坐下喝咖啡时，亨利滑到了桌子上。“谁想要个吻？”
She stuck out her tongue and he accepted the tip gingerly between his upper and lower beak. I'd never dream of doing such a thing. Not because it's across the board disgusting, but because he would have bitten the [BLEEP] out of me.
她伸出舌头，它小心翼翼地把吻接在上下喙之间。我做梦都不会做那种事。不是因为这令人作呕，而是因为他会把我的肉咬掉。
While Henry might occasionally have fanned his tail in my direction, it was understood that he was loyal to only one person. Which, I think, is another reason my sister was so fond of him.
虽然亨利偶尔会朝着我的方向扇动尾巴，但大家都明白他只忠于一个人。我想，这也是我姐姐如此喜欢他的另一个原因。
"Was that a good kiss?" she asked. "Did you like that?"
“那是个好吻吗？”她问。“你喜欢吗？”
I expected a yes or no answer and was disappointed when he responded with the exact same question, "did you like that?"
我以为他会回答是或不是，但当他用完全同样的问题回应时，我感到失望：“你喜欢吗？”
Yes, parrots can talk, but unfortunately they have no idea what they're actually saying. When she first got him, Henry spoke the Spanish he'd learned from his captors. When our mother died, Henry learned how to cry. He and Lisa would set each other off and the two of them would go on for hours.
是的，鹦鹉会说话，但不幸的是，它们根本不知道自己在说什么。她刚得到他时，亨利说的是他从劫持者那里学来的西班牙语。母亲去世时，亨利学会了哭泣。他和丽莎会互相触发，他们俩能这样持续几个小时。
A few years later, in the midst of a brief academic setback, she trained him to act as her emotional cheerleader. I'd call and hear him in the background screaming, "we love you, Lisa!" "And you can do it!"
几年后，在一次简短的学术挫折中，她训练他作为她的情感啦啦队长。我会打电话，在背景里听到他尖叫：“我们爱你，丽莎！”“你能做到的！”
This was replaced, in time, with the far more practical, where are my keys?
这后来被一个更实际的“我的钥匙在哪里？”所取代。
After finishing our coffees, Lisa drove me to Greensboro where I delivered my scheduled lecture. This is to say that I read stories about my family. After the reading I answered questions about them, thinking all the while how odd it was that these strangers seemed to know so much about my brother and sisters.
喝完咖啡后，丽莎开车送我去了格林斯博罗，我在那里做了预定的演讲。也就是说，我读了关于我家人的故事。阅读结束后，我回答了关于他们的问题，一直想着这些陌生人似乎对我的兄弟姐妹了解那么多是多么奇怪。
In order to sleep at night, I have to remove myself from the equation, pretending that the people I love voluntarily chose to expose themselves. Amy breaks up with a boyfriend and sends out a press release. Hall regularly discusses his bowel movements on daytime talk shows. I'm not the conduit, but just a poor typist stuck in the middle. It's an illusion much harder to maintain when a family member is actually in the audience.
为了晚上能睡着觉，我必须把自己从这个等式中剔除，假装我爱的人是自愿选择曝光自己的。艾米和男朋友分手并发布新闻稿。霍尔经常在日间谈话节目中讨论他的排便情况。我不是传播者，我只是个夹在中间的可怜打字员。当家庭成员真正在现场时，这种错觉就很难维持了。
The day after the reading Lisa called in sick and we spent the afternoon running errands. Winston-Salem is a city of plazas, mid-sized shopping centers each built around an enormous grocery store. I was looking for cheap cartons of cigarettes and so we drove from plaza to plaza. Lisa had officially quit smoking 10 years earlier and might have taken it up again were it not for Jessie, who according to the vet, was predisposed towards lung ailments.
阅读结束后的第二天，丽莎请了病假，我们下午在跑腿。温斯顿-塞勒姆是一个广场城市，中等规模的购物中心每个都围绕着一家巨大的杂货店而建。我在找廉价香烟，所以我们从一个广场开到另一个广场。丽莎在10年前正式戒烟，如果不是因为杰西，她可能又会抽起来，据兽医说，杰西有肺病倾向。
"I don't want to give her secondhand emphysema, but I sure wouldn't mind taking some of this weight off. Tell me the truth, do I look fat to you?"
“我不想给她二手肺气肿，但我确实不介意减掉一点体重。说实话，你觉得我胖吗？”
Not at all.
一点也不。
She turned sideways and examined herself in the front window of Tobacco USA. "You're lying."
她侧过身，在 Tobacco USA 的前窗审视自己。“你在撒谎。”
"Well, isn't that what you want me to say?"
“嗯，那不是你希望我说的吗？”
"Yeah," she said. "But I want you to really mean it."
“是的，”她说，“但我希望你是真心的。”
But I had meant it. It wasn't the weight I noticed so much as the clothing she wore to cover it up. The loose, baggy pants and oversized shirts falling halfway to her knees. This was a look she'd adopted a few months earlier, after she and her husband had gone to the mountains to visit Bob's parents. Lisa had been sitting beside the fire and when she scooted her chair towards the center of the room, her father-in-law said, "what's the matter, Lisa, getting too fat? I mean, hot." "Getting too hot?" He tried to cover his mistake, but it was too late. The word had already been seared into my sister's brain.
但我确实是真心的。我注意到的不是体重，而是她穿的那些用来遮盖身材的衣服。宽松、肥大的裤子和盖住膝盖一半的大号衬衫。这是她几个月前和她丈夫去山上探望鲍勃的父母后采用的一种造型。丽莎当时坐在火炉旁，当她把椅子挪到房间中央时，她的公公说：“怎么了，丽莎，是不是太胖了？我是说，太热了。”“太热了吗？”他试图掩盖自己的失误，但为时已晚。这个词已经烙印在我姐姐的大脑里了。
"Will I have to be fat in the movie?" she asked.
“我在电影里必须演个胖子吗？”她问。
"Of course not," I said. "You'll be just like you are."
“当然不用，”我说，“你就保持现在的样子就行。”
"Like I am according to who," she asked, "the Chinese?"
“按照谁的说法保持现在的样子？”她问，“中国人的吗？”
"Well, not all of them," I said. "Just one."
“嗯，也不是所有人，”我说，“只有一个。”
She tugged at the hem of her shirt and asked how much I thought he weighed. In truth, he was half her size, but I lied, giving him an extra hundred pounds.
她拉了拉衬衫下摆，问我猜他有多重。事实上，他只有她一半大小，但我撒了谎，给他加了一百磅。
Normally if at home during a weekday, Lisa likes to read 18th century novels, breaking at 1:00 to eat lunch and watch a television program called Matlock . By the time we finished with my errands, the day's broadcast had already ended and so we decided to go to the movies, whatever she wanted.
通常情况下，如果工作日在家，丽莎喜欢读18世纪的小说，在一点钟休息吃午饭并看一部叫《梅特洛克》（Matlock）的电视节目。等我们办完事，当天的节目已经结束了，所以我们决定去看电影，无论她想看什么。
She chose the story of a young English woman struggling to remain happy while trying to lose a few extra pounds. But in the end, she got her plazas confused and we arrived at the wrong theater just in time to watch, You Can Count on Me , the Kenny Lonergan movie in which an errant brother visits his older sister.
她选择了那个关于一个年轻英国女性为了瘦几磅而努力保持快乐的故事。但最后，她搞错了广场，我们到了错误的剧院，刚好赶上看了《你可以依靠我》（You Can Count on Me），那部肯尼斯·罗纳根（Kenny Lonergan）的电影，讲述了一个流浪哥哥拜访他姐姐的故事。
Normally Lisa's the type who talks from one end of the picture to the other. A character will spread mayonnaise onto a chicken sandwich and she'll lean over whispering, "one time. One time I was doing that and the knife fell into the toilet."
通常丽莎那种人会从电影开头谈到结尾。一个角色会在鸡肉三明治上涂蛋黄酱，她会倾过身子低声说：“有一次。有一次我正做这件事，刀掉进了马桶里。”
Then she'll settle back in her seat and I'll spend the next 10 minutes wondering why on earth someone would make a chicken sandwich in the bathroom.
然后她会回到座位上，我会花接下来的10分钟想为什么会有人在浴室里做鸡肉三明治。
This movie reflected our lives so eerily that for the first time in recent memory she was stunned into silence. There was no physical resemblance between us and the main characters. The brother and sister were younger and orphaned. But like us, they'd stumbled to adulthood playing the worn, confining roles assigned to them as children.
这部电影如此阴森地反映了我们的生活，以至于她在那次记忆中第一次被惊得哑口无言。我们和主角之间没有任何身体上的相似之处。那对兄妹更年轻，是孤儿。但就像我们一样，他们跌跌撞撞地步入成年，扮演着童年时期分配给他们的陈旧、狭隘的角色。
Every now and then one of them would break free, but for the most part they behaved not like they wanted to, but as they were expected to. In brief, a guy shows up at his sister's house and stays for a few weeks until she kicks him out. She's not evil about it, but having him around forces her to think about things she'd rather not. Which is essentially, what family members do. At least, the family members my sister and I know.
每隔一段时间，其中一人会试图挣脱，但大多数时候他们的表现不像他们想要的那样，而是表现得就像人们期望他们那样。简单来说，一个家伙出现在他姐姐家里待了几周，直到她把他赶走。她并不恶毒，但他的存在迫使她去思考她宁愿不去思考的事情。这本质上就是家庭成员做的事。至少，是我和我姐姐认识的家庭成员。
On leaving the theater we shared a long, uncomfortable silence. Between the movie we'd just seen and the movie about to be made, we both felt awkward and self-conscious, as if we were auditioning for the roles of ourselves. I started in with some benign bit of gossip I'd heard concerning the man who'd played the part of the brother, but stopped after the first few minutes saying that, on second thought, it really wasn't very interesting. She couldn't think of anything either and so we said nothing. Each of us imagining a bored audience shifting in their seats.
离开剧院时，我们经历了一段漫长、尴尬的沉默。在刚才看到的电影和即将拍摄的电影之间，我们都感到笨拙和不自在，好像我们在为自己的角色试镜一样。我开始说一些关于那个饰演哥哥的演员的无伤大雅的八卦，但说了几分钟后就停了下来，说仔细想想，这真没什么意思。她也想不出什么，所以我们什么也没说。我们每个人都在想象一个厌烦的观众在座位上不安地挪动。
We stopped for gas on the way home and we're parking in front of her house when she turned to relate what I've come to think of as the quintessential Lisa story. "One time," she said. "One time I was out driving." The incident began with a quick trip to the grocery store and ended unexpectedly, with a wounded animal stuffed into a pillowcase and held to the tailpipe of her car.
回家路上我们在加油，把车停在她家门口时，她转过身来讲述我心目中那个典型的丽莎故事。“有一次，”她说，“有一次我开车出门。”这个事件始于一次去杂货店的快速旅行，结束于意外的结果：一只受伤的动物被塞进枕套里，被紧贴在她汽车的排气管上。
Like most of my sister's stories, it provoked a startling mental picture. Capturing a moment in time when one's actions seemed both unimaginably cruel and completely natural. Details were carefully chosen and the pace built gradually. Punctuated by a series of well timed pauses. And then. And then. She reached the inevitable conclusion and just as I started to laugh, she put her head against the steering wheel and fell apart.
像我姐姐大多数故事一样，它引出了一个令人震惊的心理画面。捕捉到了这样一个时刻：当一个人的行为看起来既不可思议地残酷又完全自然。细节经过精心选择，节奏逐渐建立。以一系列精心安排的停顿来强调。然后。然后。她到了必然的结局，就在我开始笑的时候，她把头靠在方向盘上，崩溃了。
It wasn't the gentle flow of tears you might release when recalling an isolated action or event, but the violent explosion that comes when you realize that all such events are connected, forming an endless chain of guilt and suffering. I instinctively reach for the notebook I keep in my pocket.
这不像那种你在回忆一个孤立的动作或事件时可能会流下的温柔泪水，而是在你意识到所有这些事件都是相关联的，形成了一条无休止的负罪感和痛苦的链条时，所产生的剧烈爆炸。我本能地伸手去拿我放在口袋里的笔记本。
And she grabbed my hand to stop me. If you ever, she said, ever, repeat that story, I will never talk to you again. In the movie version of our lives I would have turned to offer her comfort, reminding her, convincing her, that the actions she described had been kind and just. Because it was. She's incapable of acting otherwise.
她抓住了我的手来阻止我。如果你曾经，她说，曾经，重复那个故事，我就再也不跟你说话了。在我们生活的电影版本里，我会转过身去安慰她，提醒她，让她相信她描述的行为是善良和公正的。因为事实就是这样。她不可能做出其他举动。
In the real version of our lives, my immediate goal was simply to change her mind. "Oh, come on," I said. "That story's really funny and I mean, it's not like you're going to do anything with it." Your life, your privacy, your bottomless sorrow, it's not like you're going to do anything with it. Is this the brother I always was or the brother I have become?
在我们生活的真实版本里，我的直接目标只是想改变她的想法。“哦，得了吧，”我说。“那个故事真的很有趣，我是说，又不是说你会拿它做什么。”你的生活、你的隐私、你无底的悲伤，又不是说你会拿它做什么。这是我一直以来的那个兄弟，还是我已经变成的那个兄弟？
I'd worried that in making the movie the director might get me and my family wrong. But now a worse thought occurred to me, what if he got us right?
我曾担心导演在制作电影时可能会误解我和我的家人。但现在一个更糟糕的想法出现了：如果他把我们完全理解对了呢？
Dusk. The camera pans an unremarkable suburban street, moving in on a parked four-door automobile where a small, evil man turns to his sobbing sister saying, "what if I use this story but say that it happened to a friend?"
黄昏。摄像机扫过一条不起眼的郊区街道，聚焦于一辆停放的四门汽车上，里面一个邪恶的小男人转过头对他啜泣的姐姐说：“如果我用这个故事，但说是发生在一个朋友身上，会怎样？”
But maybe that's not the end. Maybe before the credits roll we see this same man getting out of bed in the middle of the night, walking past his sister's bedroom, and downstairs into the kitchen. A switch is thrown and we notice in the far corner of the room, a large, standing bird cage covered with a tablecloth. He approaches it carefully and removes the cover, waking a Blue-fronted Amazon parrot. Its eyes glowing red in the sudden light.
但也许那不是结尾。也许在字幕滚动之前，我们看到同一个男人在半夜起床，走过姐姐的卧室，下楼走进厨房。开关打开了，我们注意到房间远角处有一个覆盖着桌布的大型站立鸟笼。他小心翼翼地走过去拿开盖子，叫醒了一只蓝额亚马逊鹦鹉。它的眼睛在突然的光线下发出红光。
Through everything that's come before this moment, we understand that the man has something important to say. From his own mouth the words are meaningless and so he pulls up a chair. The clock reads 3:00 AM, then 4:00, then 5:00 as he sits before the brilliant bird, repeating slowly and clearly the words forgive me. Forgive me. Forgive me.
通过在这瞬间之前发生的一切，我们明白那个男人有重要的话要说。从他自己的嘴里说出来，这些词毫无意义，所以他拉过一把椅子。时钟指向凌晨3点，然后是4点，然后是5点，他坐在聪明的鸟面前，缓慢而清晰地重复着“原谅我”。原谅我。原谅我。
David Sedaris. That story appears on his Live at Carnegie Hall CD and also in his new book, Dress Your Family in Corduroy and Denim. Coming up, what your six year old could probably teacher your doctor. No kidding. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
大卫·塞达里斯。那个故事出现在他的 CD《Live at Carnegie Hall》中，也收录在他的新书《Dress Your Family in Corduroy and Denim》中。接下来，你的六岁孩子可能可以教你医生什么。没开玩笑。从芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，一分钟后节目继续。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, apologies. Stories of people struggling to apologize against some difficult odds. We've arrived act two of our show. Act two, "Dial S for Sorry."
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们当然会选择一个主题，带给你关于那个主题的各种各样的故事。今天的节目是道歉。关于人们在一些困难的环境下挣扎着道歉的故事。我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“拨S代表抱歉”。
In 1980, a New Yorker named Allan Bridge set up a telephone line that he called The Apology Line. And the way it worked was that you could call and confess to anything you wanted and you'd be recorded. Or you could call and you could listen to other people's confessions. And over time-- this is all pre-internet days. Over time, the whole thing turned into this little community of confession. People recorded messages responding to each other's apologies. Mr. Apology, Allan Bridge, would leave messages responding to messages himself. Or sometimes he would call callers off the line and talk to them.
1980年，一位名叫艾伦·布里奇（Allan Bridge）的纽约人设立了一条电话线，他称之为“道歉热线”（The Apology Line）。它的运作方式是你可以打电话忏悔任何你想忏悔的事情，你会录下来。或者你可以打电话听别人的忏悔。随着时间的推移——这都是互联网时代之前的事了——整件事变成了一个忏悔的小社区。人们录下信息回应彼此的道歉。道歉先生，也就是艾伦·布里奇，会留下信息回应他自己的信息。或者有时他会给打电话的人回电跟他们交谈。
Back in 1997 we played some recordings from the line on our program. We've never rerun it and we thought it might be appropriate to hear some of them today.
1997年，我们在节目中播放了一些来自热线的录音。我们从未重播过它，我们觉得今天听听其中的一些可能很合适。
Yes, I'd like to apologize because I have broke the town hall windows, I flooded the basement, I broke windows on the back of a store uptown. I feel pretty bad about it because I did so much violence. I'm only 16 years old. I did so much violence and if I was caught, I'd be in juvie hall for a pretty long time I'd say. I'm sorry for harassing the Republican officials, making the bomb threats and the death notices. I'm sorry for the terrorism, the fire bombing that the guy paid me to do to some guy's house. I'm sorry for the burnings in the streets of Smithtown, Long Island.
是的，我想道歉，因为我打破了市政厅的窗户，我淹没了地下室，我打破了城里一家商店后面的窗户。我对此感觉很不好，因为我做了那么多的暴力行为。我只有16岁。我做了那么多暴力行为，如果我被抓到，我想我会在少管所待很长一段时间。我很抱歉骚扰了共和党官员，制造了炸弹威胁和死亡通知。我很抱歉制造了恐怖主义，以及那个人花钱雇我对他人的房子进行纵火。我很抱歉在长岛史密斯镇的街道上制造了纵火。
I'm sorry for the way I'm calling right now. I'm calling by way of a phony credit card. I'm sorry for harassing the teacher in school. I feel bad about it. I'd like to have a new lease on life.
我很抱歉我现在的拨号方式。我是通过伪造的信用卡拨打的。我很抱歉在学校骚扰了老师。我对此感觉很不好。我希望能有新的生活。
What else? I'm sorry for just harassing a lot of people. For causing pain to my family. I felt so sad I was sick. I was sick by it. That's all I have to say. So long.
还有什么？我很抱歉骚扰了很多人。给我的家人造成了痛苦。我感觉很悲伤，我病了。我为此感到生病。这就是我要说的全部。再见。
Yeah, I want to apologize for something and maybe-- well, I guess it's too late to apologize for it, but I want to apologize for it now.
是的，我想为某件事道歉，也许——好吧，我想现在道歉已经太晚了，但我现在想为它道歉。
My mother was bedridden for a while and she had to get social security and welfare. And I had no job and I had no way of making money. And when she was hungry or thirsty I used to make her give me money to give her a drink. Like she'd have to give me $5 for a glass of water, $10 for a sandwich. Now she's passed away and I can't say I'm sorry to her. Because I know what I did was probably the most horrible thing in the world and I'll never be able to say I'm sorry to her. I hope I go to hell and burn there for this because it wasn't right. And if there's some way that she can hear me I just want to tell her I'm sorry. Thank you.
我母亲有一段时间卧床不起，她不得不领取社会保障和福利。我没有工作，没有赚钱的方法。当她饿了或渴了的时候，我过去常常让她给我钱才给她水喝。比如她得给我5美元才能喝上一杯水，10美元吃个三明治。现在她去世了，我没法对她说对不起。因为我知道我所做的一切可能是世界上最可怕的事，我将永远没法对她说对不起。我希望我下地狱并在那里燃烧，因为那是不对的。如果有某种方式她能听到我，我只想告诉她我很抱歉。谢谢。
I've never told anyone this except my shrink. I accidentally killed my younger sister when I was a very small child and it's haunted me all my life because I didn't really mean it. It was just a game to me and I was really too young to realize what I was doing. And I was putting her head inside a plastic garbage bag and putting a rubber band around her neck just to see her face turn blue. I guess it was a lot of fun and I didn't mean anything bad to happen. But I guess I didn't realize what would happen if I did this too long and she suffocated. I hid the plastic bag and I went out of the house. My parents weren't home. And they never found out. They thought it was crib death. They never found out I did it.
我除了心理医生从来没告诉过任何人。我还是个小孩的时候不小心杀了我妹妹，这困扰了我一生，因为我不是故意的。对我来说那只是个游戏，我真的太小了，没意识到我在做什么。我把她的头放进一个塑料垃圾袋里，在她的脖子上套了一根橡皮筋，只是想看她的脸变蓝。我想那很有趣，我不是存心想发生任何坏事。但我猜我没意识到如果我做太久会发生什么，结果她窒息了。我藏起了那个塑料袋，跑出了屋子。我父母当时不在家。他们从没发现。他们以为那是摇篮死。他们永远不知道是我干的。
I've never been able to tell them. I think it would hurt them worse than losing her to find out that I did it. I kind of wish my parents could hear this tape, but I guess they never will.
我从来没能告诉他们。我想如果他们发现是我干的，那对他们来说比失去她更痛苦。我有点希望我父母能听到这段录音，但我想他们永远不会了。
Hi, I'm a runaway and all I want to say is that I'm kind of sorry that I left. See, I'm 15 and I saw your number in the newspaper. When I saw it, I had to call because I mean, you walk around on the streets all day long just looking for someone that just might say, hey, want a place to go? Come with me. They'll give you food and everything. And they won't ask or anything back. That's all I want. I guess I take up too much time on the tape. But I just got to talk.
嗨，我是一个离家出走的孩子，我只想说我很抱歉我离开了。你看，我15岁，我在报纸上看到了你的号码。当我看到它时，我不得不打过来，因为我是说，你整天在街上走来走去，只是在寻找一个可能会说“嘿，想找个地方去吗？跟我来”的人。他们会给你食物和一切。他们什么回报都不会要求。这就是我想要的。我想我在录音带上占用了太多时间。但我只是不得不说出来。
The Apology Line doesn't exist anymore. Mr. Apology, Allan Bridge, died in August of 1995. When he did, the line was deluged with hundreds of messages from its regular callers, grieving. His wife, Marissa, says it was never clearer what The Apology Line had meant to people.
“道歉热线”已经不存在了。道歉先生，艾伦·布里奇，死于1995年8月。当他去世时，热线被几百名常客留下的信息淹没了，他们都在哀悼。他的妻子玛丽莎（Marissa）说，道歉热线对人们的意义从未如此清晰。
For years, people had used it to talk about all sorts of experiences.
多年来，人们用它来谈论各种各样的经历。
I think that maybe the word "apology" means something bigger than just saying you're sorry. Or at least maybe not the word, but the line came to mean to people a place where one could go and bring their feelings. To confess not necessarily about doing something wrong, but to confess about having a feeling.
我认为也许“道歉”这个词的意义不仅仅是说对不起。或者至少也许不是这个词，而是这条热线对人们来说意味着一个可以去表达自己感受的地方。忏悔的不仅仅是做错了什么，而是忏悔自己的某种感受。
When he was alive, would you ever call the line or be tempted to call the line?
当他活着的时候，你会打这条热线，或者有冲动去打吗？
I called the line in the beginning when I first knew him, before I moved in with him. I called the line from time to time.
我在刚认识他的时候，在他和我同居之前打过热线。我偶尔会打。
And you'd apologize for stuff?
你会为一些事情道歉？
Well, yeah, sometimes. But more to get his attention than anything else I think. So he wouldn't forget about me up in Washington Heights where I was living.
嗯，是的，有时会。但我认为更多是为了引起他的注意，而不是其他任何原因。这样他就不会忘记住在华盛顿高地的我了。
What would you apologize for back then? Do you remember what you would say?
那时你会为什么而道歉？你记得你会说什么吗？
Oh, they were all like, you know, just to get his attention. Things like, I'm really sorry I was flirting with another guy or something like that. Much part of the mating game.
哦，都是一些，你知道的，只是为了引起他的注意。诸如“我很抱歉我和另一个男人调情了”之类的事情。很大程度上是求偶博弈的一部分。
But once you actually had a real relationship with him, you wouldn't call the line and you didn't feel a need to ever?
但一旦你和他建立了真正的关系，你就不会打热线了，你也不觉得有任何需要？
No, but one thing that really struck me was after he died, I really turned into an Apology Line caller. Someone I would define as Apology Line caller. And the line was over, so when I really needed the line it wasn't there. I was just completely lost and I would have loved to have been able to call The Apology Line and have someone like Allan on the other side, very sympathetic and understanding, to help me get through it. But unfortunately, that didn't happen. I'm a much darker person than I was before he died and I think that I understand the caller's and the line much better than I even did before.
不，但有一件事真正震撼了我，在他死后，我真的变成了一个道歉热线的呼叫者。一个我会定义为道歉热线呼叫者的人。但热线已经结束了，所以当我真正需要热线时，它已经不在了。我完全迷失了，我真希望当时能打通道歉热线，让像艾伦那样的人在另一端，非常富有同情心和理解力，帮助我度过难关。但不幸的是，这没发生。我比他去世前变成了一个阴暗得多的人，我认为我比以前更能理解那些打热线的人了。
He died in this scuba accident where he was hit by a jet skier who then fled the scene and wasn't caught. Have you thought about the kinds of people who would call the line, who used to call the line all the time, who had done bad things to other people and hurt other people, and then would flee the scene and nobody would ever know. Have you thought about those jet skiers in terms of that, in terms of the people who used to call the line?
他死于一场水肺潜水事故，当时他被一名摩托艇手撞了，对方随后逃离现场，且没被抓住。你有没有想过那些打热线的人，那些一直打热线的人，那些对别人做了坏事并伤害了别人，然后会逃离现场且没人会知道的人？你有没有从这个角度，从那些打热线的人的角度去想过那些摩托艇手？
Yes, in fact, the person that hit him would also be a prime candidate for The Apology Line. Because we think that he knew that he did something because there were witnesses that saw the accident and they saw someone on a jet ski hit him. They circled around once and then took off. Yeah.
是的，事实上，撞他的那个人也是道歉热线的最佳候选人。因为我们认为他知道自己做了什么，因为有目击者看到了事故，他们看到了有人骑着摩托艇撞了他。他们绕了一圈然后逃走了。是的。
But you can imagine those people actually calling the line? If they would have called the line, if the line had existed for them, what would have happen? What would Mr. Apology have said if he were around to say it?
但你能想象这些人真的打热线吗？如果他们打过热线，如果热线为他们存在过，会发生什么？如果道歉先生还在世的话，他会说什么？
I think he would be pretty pissed off, but he would forgive them. I think that's how he would have gone for it. I think he would have been angry that he was hit. That was a total accident. But I think that if they would have apologized for hitting him he would have forgiven them. Because I think that forgiveness was a big part of his personality. I think he really believed in the power of forgiveness. And everyone can be forgiven if they're sorry. I think that's something that he really believed in.
我想他会很生气，但他会原谅他们。我想这就是他的处理方式。我想他会因为自己被撞而生气。那完全是一场意外。但我认为，如果他们为撞他而道歉，他会原谅他们的。因为我认为宽恕是他性格中很大的一部分。我想他真的相信宽恕的力量。每个人如果感到抱歉都可以被原谅。我想这是他真心相信的东西。
Marissa Bridge. The Apology Line is still down, but there's a website with clips and transcripts and a CD for sale, www.apologyproject.com.
玛丽莎·布里奇。道歉热线现在已经关闭，但有一个网站有剪辑和文字记录，还有一张CD在出售，www.apologyproject.com。
[MUSIC- "I'M CONFESSIN' (THAT I LOVE YOU)" BY BRENDA LEE]
[音乐 - 布伦达·李的《我忏悔（我爱你）》]
Act three, "Two Words You Never Want to Hear from Your Doctor."
第三幕，“医生永远不想从你口中听到的两个词”。
There are somewhere between 44,000 and 195,000 fatal medical errors in hospitals every year, depending on what study you look at. But those errors don't translate into 44,000 to 195,000 apologies from doctors. Starlee Kine says this may be changing, but very, very slowly.
每年医院发生的致命医疗事故在44,000到195,000起之间，具体取决于你参考的研究。但这些错误并不能转化为44,000到195,000次来自医生的道歉。斯塔丽·凯恩（Starlee Kine）说，这种情况可能正在改变，但非常、非常缓慢。
Five years ago, 39 year old Michael Lang had a stomach ache that was causing him a lot of pain. That night he checked into the local emergency room. The staff looked at him briefly and decided his condition wasn't too serious. The family says his mother talked to a nurse and requested an ultrasound, but that was rebuffed. Michael was given morphine for the pain and told he'd be able to go home the next morning.
五年前，39岁的迈克尔·朗（Michael Lang）患有严重的胃痛。那天晚上他住进了当地的急诊室。医护人员简短地看了他一眼，认为他的情况不太严重。家人说他的母亲曾和护士交谈并要求进行超声波检查，但被拒绝了。迈克尔被注射了吗啡缓解疼痛，并被告知第二天早上可以回家。
Overnight, he died of an internal hemorrhage and blood around his heart. The hospital called Mike's parents and told them that his condition had worsened, but not that he had died. They got in their car and rushed over. This is Mike's sister, Roxanne.
一夜之间，他死于内出血和心脏周围的积血。医院给迈克的父母打了电话，告诉他们他的病情恶化了，但没说他已经死了。他们开车赶了过去。这是迈克的姐姐，罗珊（Roxanne）。
On the way there my parents start talking about taking him somewhere else, not realizing that he was already dead. And when they arrived at the hospital, no one was there to meet them and they took the elevator up to the second floor. And when the door opened, a lot of the nurses were standing there whispering. And when my mom looked at one of the nurses, she knew and she turned to my dad and said, he's dead, Ray.
在路上，我父母开始讨论带他去别的地方，没意识到他已经死了。当他们到达医院时，没人接应他们，他们乘电梯上了二楼。当门打开时，很多护士站在那里窃窃私语。当妈妈看着其中一个护士时，她知道了，她转头对爸爸说，他死了，雷（Ray）。
And they ran down the hall to his room where Mike was lying in the bed with the IV still in his arm. It was hanging over the side and my dad tried to put it under the sheet, but was unable to bend it. The thing that they remember the most is going over to him and trying to hug him. And he was, you know, stiff and cold. That's their memory of their son.
他们跑下走廊冲进他的房间，迈克正躺在床上，静脉输液管还在他胳膊上。输液管挂在床边，爸爸想把它放进床单下面，但无法弯曲它。他们印象最深的是走到他身边想拥抱他。而他已经僵硬冰凉了。这就是他们对自己儿子的记忆。
It's not just the fact that the doctors didn't catch what was wrong with their son, but the way they were treated by the hospital that haunts Roxanne's family. How they were disregard when they asked for an ultrasound. How they were allowed to drive over thinking Mike was still live. And then how no one was waiting for them with the tragic news once they got there.
不仅是医生没发现他们儿子的问题，更让罗珊一家无法释怀的是医院对待他们的方式。他们要求超声波检查时是如何被无视的。他们被允许继续开车，以为迈克还活着。然后当他们到达那里时，没有人等待他们告诉这个悲惨的消息。
In the weeks that followed, the things the hospital did just made it worse, as far as the family was concerned. When asked why they hadn't been more attentive to Mike, the hospital said they'd been busy that night with an emergency accident. They denied all responsibility for Mike's death.
在接下来的几周里，医院所做的一切只会让事情变得更糟，至少在家人看来是这样。当被问及为什么对迈克不够细心时，医院说那天晚上他们正忙于一起紧急事故。他们否认了迈克死亡的所有责任。
The town in Wisconsin where this happened is small. Roxanne's parents go to the same church as the hospital's CEO. Roxanne says they never talk. It's awkward. Almost the only communication they've had from him was in a letter he sent after Mike's death.
发生这件事的威斯康星州小镇很小。罗珊的父母和医院首席执行官去同一家教堂。罗珊说他们从来不说话。这很尴尬。他们从他那里得到的几乎唯一的交流是迈克死后他寄来的一封信。
He basically said Mike didn't die of a medical error and we have no responsibility for his death at this hospital. We had several committees that investigated it and reviewed everything and we made no mistakes here. Basically, he said we didn't have any part in it. But still, no answers. Still no apologies.
他基本上说迈克不是死于医疗事故，我们对他在这家医院的死亡不负任何责任。我们有几个委员会调查并审查了一切，我们在这里没犯任何错误。基本上，他说我们与此无关。但仍然，没有答案。仍然没有道歉。
No?
没有？
No. And the thing about the letter was is he addressed them by their first names, Ray and Betty. Dear Ray and Betty. To me, that was an insult when I read that. I was just like, how can you be so familiar with my parents when you can't even apologize for their son dying in your facility?
没有。那封信的问题在于他称呼他们为名字：雷和贝蒂。亲爱的雷和贝蒂。对我来说，当我读到这时，这是一种侮辱。我当时就想，当你甚至不能为你儿子在你的设施里死亡而道歉时，你怎么能对我的父母表现得如此亲昵？
Well, see, an apology, why do you apologize to somebody-- because you did something wrong?
嗯，你看，道歉，你为什么向某人道歉——因为你做错了事？
This is the CEO of the hospital, John Landdeck. He and Roxanne don't see the situation the same at all. For him it's like this-- the hospital wasn't at fault from Mike's death. An independent medical commission that looked into the case cleared them of wrongdoing. And besides, he's not even sure the hospital didn't apologize.
这是医院的首席执行官约翰·兰德克（John Landdeck）。他和罗珊对情况的看法完全不同。对他来说是这样的——医院对迈克的死亡没有过错。一个调查此案的独立医疗委员会清除了他们的不当行为。而且，他不确定医院没道歉。
To the extent that we failed to communicate our sympathy with them, that's bad. But you know, a family facing the sudden loss of an otherwise normal, healthy, young man doesn't always hear and see everything that's going on either. And those nurses might have said things and we might have and the doctor might have that they completely missed in their grief.
在某种程度上，我们没能向他们表达同情，那是糟糕的。但你知道，一个面临着否则本来健康、正常的年轻人突然去世的家庭，并不总是能听见或看见正在发生的一切。那些护士可能说了些话，我们可能说了些话，医生可能说了些话，但在他们的悲痛中，他们完全错过了。
Do you think when the family started saying stuff like, you know, there was a medical error, he died of a medical error. It was the hospital's fault, stuff like that that the hospital went on the defensive though?
你认为当家人开始说比如，你知道，这存在医疗事故，他死于医疗事故，这是医院的错，诸如此类的话时，医院是否采取了防御姿态？
Well, we tried not to. I'm sure that everybody felt that way. If somebody says you're bad and you know you're not and the first thing is to set out to prove that you're right.
嗯，我们尽量不这样。我相信每个人都会有那种感觉。如果有人说你很糟糕，而你知道你没有，第一反应就是证明你是对的。
This is really like any fight when someone asks for an apology. One side wants to prove it's not their fault, the other wants acknowledgment that their feelings are valid. There's a lot of talking past one another.
这真的像任何争吵一样，当有人要求道歉时。一方想证明不是自己的错，另一方想得到他们的感受是有效的认可。有很多谈话是各说各话。
Is part of the reason that you think you and your family and other families need to hear an apology so badly is because you're afraid that maybe when they don't say they're sorry that they don't actually feel sorry?
你认为你和你的家人以及其他家庭如此渴望听到道歉，是因为你们害怕如果他们不说对不起，他们实际上就不是真的感到抱歉吗？
Most definitely. I remember from Mike-- in Mike's situation-- is we just wanted somebody to publicly acknowledge the fact that he died and that that was an awful thing. You know, whether he died of an error or not, it was an awful thing that he died. And nobody was saying that.
绝对是。我记得迈克的情况，我们只是想让某人公开承认他已经去世的事实，并且那是一件糟糕的事情。你知道，无论他是否死于事故，他去世都是一件糟糕的事。没人这么说。
The reason doctors and hospitals don't apologize is actually pretty simple. It all comes down to malpractice insurance.
医生和医院不道歉的原因其实很简单。这完全归结为医疗事故保险。
I think historically the party line has been gag orders.
我想历史上一直以来的方针是封口令。
This is David Sousa, president of Medical Mutual Insurance Company.
这是医疗互助保险公司（Medical Mutual Insurance Company）总裁大卫·索萨（David Sousa）。
As people like us, as an insurance carrier, have seen our society become more and more litigious, it has caused us to go to our physician insureds and to caution them, unfortunately, that anything and everything that they may say in the context of a medical error, can be used against them to prove their negligence if they are sued by that patient.
像我们这样的保险公司看到我们的社会变得越来越爱打官司，这导致我们去找我们的医生投保人，并遗憾地告诫他们，在医疗事故的背景下，任何他们可能说的话，如果他们被病人起诉，都可能被用来证明他们的疏忽。
When those kinds of things started happening, we started counseling doctors, much to our chagrin, you need to not have these conversations with your patients. Or if you do have to have them, they've got to be almost sterile in nature so that the patient can't come back and use that against you if they try to sue.
当这些事情开始发生时，我们开始建议医生——令我们懊恼的是——你需要不要和你的病人进行这些谈话。或者如果你不得不进行，它们必须本质上是近乎无菌的，这样病人就没法回头利用这些来对付你，如果他们试图起诉的话。
Over time, that has had an incredible chilling effect on the ability of doctors to just openly communicate with their patients when something goes wrong.
随着时间的推移，这对医生在出错时与病人公开沟通的能力产生了极大的寒蝉效应。
And you actually had these conversations with doctors where you would advise them to not say anything?
你真的和医生进行过这些谈话，建议他们什么都不要说？
Repeatedly. Repeatedly. Absolutely.
反复地。反复地。绝对是。
This is all changing though. The shift began back in the '80s when Lexington, Kentucky Veteran's Hospital lost a series of malpractice suits and decided to try an experiment.
不过这一切都在改变。这种转变始于80年代，当时列克星敦肯塔基退伍军人医院输掉了一系列医疗事故诉讼，并决定尝试一个实验。
The doctors were told that they had to disclose fully and immediately any medical error to patients. And also, apologize if it was appropriate.
医生被告知他们必须完全、立即向病人披露任何医疗错误。而且，如果合适的话，还要道歉。
In 10 years, the hospital went from having some of the highest legal costs in the state to some of the lowest. Meanwhile, the laws in certain states started changing so that when a doctor apologizes it can't be used against them in a lawsuit. There are now laws like that in nine states. Some apply to any kind of apology made in any civil suit. The new ones specifically apply to medical errors. Again, David Sousa from the insurance industry.
在10年里，这家医院从州内法律费用最高之一降到了最低之一。同时，某些州的法律开始改变，这样当医生道歉时，这些话就不能在诉讼中用来对付他们。现在有9个州有这样的法律。有些适用于任何民事诉讼中的任何道歉。新的法律专门适用于医疗错误。再一次，来自保险业的大卫·索萨。
Now in our state here North Carolina, a statement made that is tantamount to an apology can not be used against that health care provider to prove negligence in a court room. That's huge. It really opens the door now for us to say, now not only do we believe it's the right thing to do, but now you're protected when you do it. And that's huge. That's just giant.
现在在我们北卡罗来纳州，作为道歉陈述的言论不能在法庭上被用来证明医务提供者的疏忽。这太棒了。它真的打开了大门，让我们现在可以说，不仅我们相信这是正确的事，而且现在你在做的时候也会受到保护。这太棒了。这是巨大的。
The apology. The apology. [LAUGHTER]
道歉。道歉。[笑声]
Tucked away in the basement of Johns Hopkins Medical School through a door that I thought was a fire exit, in a little room that reminded me of the smoking stairwell from college is a movie studio, an instructional movie studio. Dr. Albert Wu, an associate professor at John Hopkins, is shooting a training video here. It's called, "Disclosing Errors and Adverse Outcomes. The Who, What, Where, When, How, and Why of Disclosure." Or as I like to call it, being a doctor means never having to say you're sorry. Unless something goes wrong, then you really should.
在约翰·霍普金斯医学院地下室的一扇我认为是防火门后面，在一个让我想起大学吸烟楼梯间的小房间里，有一个电影工作室，一个教学电影工作室。约翰·霍普金斯大学副教授阿尔伯特·吴（Albert Wu）医生正在这里拍摄教学视频。视频标题为“披露错误和不良后果。披露的谁、什么、哪里、何时、如何和为什么”。或者正如我喜欢称之为，“作为医生意味着永远不必说对不起。除非出了差错，那时你真的应该说”。
For the past 15 years, Dr. Wu has been researching how doctors handle medical mistakes. He's talked to patient about what they actually want to hear and then traveled around presenting his findings to doctors via the magic of PowerPoint presentation.
在过去的15年里，吴医生一直在研究医生如何处理医疗错误。他与病人谈论他们真正想听到什么，然后四处奔波，通过 PowerPoint 演示文稿的魔力向医生展示他的发现。
His video walks doctors through the process of telling their patient something went wrong, baby step by baby step.
他的视频一步步引导医生完成告诉病人出了差错的过程。
Tips for disclosing. Before beginning, make sure the patient or family member is comfortable. Try not to put a desk or other barrier between you and the patient. Give the patient the opportunity to talk and ask questions about the situation. Do not ignore or dismiss strong emotions, even if you would prefer to do so.
披露的提示。在开始之前，确保病人家属感到舒适。尽量不要在病人和你之间放置桌子或其他障碍物。给病人谈论和询问情况的机会。不要忽视或无视强烈的情绪，即使你更愿意这样做。
If the patient is enraged acknowledge this by saying, I can understand why you are angry with me.
如果病人很愤怒，通过说“我可以理解你为什么生我的气”来承认这一点。
In the case of personal responsibility, express personal regret and make a sincere apology. You should say, I am sorry that I did this.
在个人责任的情况下，表达个人遗憾并做出诚挚的道歉。你应该说：“我很抱歉我造成了这一切。”
And that's that. There's no complicated formula or magic combination of phrases. It literally comes down to teaching doctors how to say the actual words, "I'm sorry."
就是这样。没有复杂的公式或魔法短语组合。这字面上归结为教导医生如何说出实际的词：“我很抱歉。”
Dr. Wu tells me that when he first started out, doctors didn't even have to tell their patients when they did something wrong, let alone apologize for it. He remembers on his first day as an intern he went to a woman's hospital room to give her a routine checkup and she had a heart attack before he could even start. A nurse was there with him.
吴医生告诉我，当他刚开始时，医生甚至不必在犯错时告诉病人，更不用说为此道歉了。他记得他作为实习生的第一天，他去一位女士的医院病房做常规检查，在他开始之前她就心脏病发作了。一位护士和他在一起。
And the person at the head of the bed said, give this. And so I took this syringe and squirted 10 milligrams of morphine into the patient's IV. And it turns out 10 milligrams of morphine is a lot morphine. What she intended me to do, I think, was for her to get maybe a milligram. Or maybe two. But not 10.
床头的人说，注射这个。所以我拿起注射器，把10毫克吗啡喷进了病人的静脉里。结果证明10毫克吗啡是很大的剂量。我想她原本打算让我给病人注射1毫克。或者也许两毫克。但不是10毫克。
She had been breathing very rapidly [HEAVY BREATHING] and it was about as clean a cause and effect relationship as one could ever see. I gave her an overdose of morphine and she stopped breathing.
她呼吸非常急促[沉重的呼吸声]，那是我见过的最清晰的因果关系。我给她注射了过量的吗啡，她停止了呼吸。
The woman was rushed off to an emergency room and was ultimately OK. Dr. Wu, on the other hand, wasn't doing so good.
那位女士被紧急送往急诊室，最终没事。而吴医生，情况不太好。
I was left there standing in the room. Hospital rooms look funny when there is no hospital bed in them. The bed had been wheeled right out of the room, syringes had been ripped out of packaging, and bottles had been hung, and there was all of this stuff all over the place. And I just sort of stood there with sort of that tingly feeling that starts in your spine and goes up to your neck. It really is a little bit like the walls are closing in on you. Unfortunately, this head nurse was standing in the corner with her arms folded and she looked at me and said, "that was a lot of morphine." And we talked a little bit about what seemed to have happened and what might have been done differently. And then, in the end, she said, well, "I don't think that anyone really needs to hear about this." And that was it.
我留在那儿站在房间里。医院病房里没有病床看起来很滑稽。床直接被推出了房间，注射器从包装中撕了出来，瓶子挂着，到处都是东西。我只是站在那儿，脊椎一直到脖子有一种刺痛的感觉。感觉真的有点像墙壁在向你合拢。不幸的是，那位护士长站在角落里双臂交叉，她看着我说：“那剂量可真大。”我们简短谈论了似乎发生了什么以及本可以做些什么不同的事。然后，最后，她说，好吧，“我不认为有人真的需要知道这件事。”就这样。
So as far as I'm aware, the patient's attending physician never heard about what had happened, the patient certainly never heard what happened. And I was relieved that I'd been let off the hook, but still felt a little uncomfortable.
据我所知，病人的主治医师从来没听说过发生了什么，病人当然也从来没听说过发生了什么。我松了一口气，因为我没惹上麻烦，但仍然感到有点不安。
When you make an error that hurts someone, you feel like you're the only person who has ever done such a thing. You feel completely isolated. There's a funny dynamic that's in effect. Doctors would like to believe that they help people. Patients desperately would like to be helped. And through a process of mutual denial, it's easy for everyone to pretend that this sort of thing happens rarely in any event, or should not happen at all. When in fact, it's quite common.
当你犯下伤害某人的错误时，你觉得你是唯一一个做出这种事的人。你感到完全被孤立。这有一种有趣的动态在起作用。医生愿意相信他们帮助了人。病人拼命地想要得到帮助。通过一种相互否认的过程，每个人都很容易假装这种事情很少发生，或者根本不应该发生。而实际上，这很常见。
In a funny way, I think it's a relief to know that there is a policy that one should disclose errors that harm the patient.
以一种有趣的方式，我认为知道有一项政策应该披露伤害病人的错误是一种解脱。
So doctors feel relieved when they apologize to their patients. And often, they want to apologize to their patients. But Dr. Wu says that doesn't mean they're any good at it.
所以医生在向病人道歉时会感到解脱。而且通常，他们想向病人道歉。但吴医生说，这并不意味着他们擅长道歉。
So often there's an apology followed immediately by an excuse.
道歉之后紧跟着往往是借口。
A small medical apology industry has recently sprung up with books, videos, and seminars, like this one with 40 doctors in North Carolina, set up by a local insurance company, and taught by Dr. Gerald Hickson from Vanderbilt University.
一个小型医疗道歉行业最近兴起，包括书籍、视频和研讨会，比如这次在北卡罗来纳州由当地保险公司设立，由范德比尔特大学的杰拉德·希克森（Gerald Hickson）医生教授的40名医生的研讨会。
He warmed up the crowd by telling the story of a pregnant woman who was treated so poorly by her doctor that she vowed never to get pregnant again, just so she wouldn't have to see him anymore. At this seminar, it becomes pretty clear that most medical errors aren't dramatic. They're not matters of life and death. Most of them are things like forgetting to follow-up and giving your patient a referral, or being half an hour late while your patient sits in the waiting room.
他讲了一个怀孕妇女的故事来热场，她被医生对待得如此糟糕，以至于她发誓再也不怀孕，只为了不必再见到他。在这次研讨会上，很清楚大多数医疗错误并不戏剧化。它们不是生死攸关的问题。大多数都是诸如忘记跟进和给病人转诊，或者迟到半小时而让病人坐在候诊室里。
Also, it's not always exactly clear if the doctors are to blame or not, even in the most seemingly cut and dry cases.
此外，医生是否应该受责备并不总是很清楚，即使在看起来最简单明了的情况下。
Something else we often see that I worry about is an apology with what I call assignment of responsibility. A finger pointed in a direction to say, well, Ms. Jones, I'm just so terribly sorry that the nurses at this institution clearly can't count right. Right? You know exactly what I'm talking about.
我们经常看到的另一件事是带有我所说的“责任分配”的道歉。手指指向一个方向说，“好吧，琼斯女士，我非常抱歉，这家机构的护士显然连数数都不会。”对吧？你知道我在说什么。
In the years since Roxanne's brother died, she has sat on panels with doctors and policymakers talking about the need to be honest with patients and admit their errors. And she's met with doctors who have been trained in this whole new way of apologizing. And she's glad for the effort, but says that a real apology isn't only about the words.
在罗珊的哥哥去世后的这些年里，她和医生以及决策者们一起坐在小组会议上谈论对病人诚实并承认错误的重要性。她遇到了受过这种全新道歉方式训练的医生。她为这种努力感到高兴，但表示真正的道歉不仅仅是关于语言。
The response that I get now when people find out, especially from health care that I lost a brother through medical error, they are in a hurry to say, I'm very sorry for your loss. Because that's what they're being taught. That they should say I'm very sorry for your loss. And for the most part, everybody's very sincere about it and I appreciate it. But you can see it's that they've been taught that phrase. That that's the phrase they should use.
当人们发现，特别是在医疗保健领域，我因为医疗事故失去了一个哥哥时，我得到的反应是他们匆忙地说，“我对你的损失深表遗憾”。因为这就是他们被教导的。他们应该说“我对你的损失深表遗憾”。在很大程度上，每个人对此都很真诚，我对此很感激。但你可以看出他们是被教导那个短语的。那是他们应该使用的短语。
How can you tell?
你怎么看出来的？
It's like the rush they need to get it out to me and this is the phrase that is used. You know, I'm sorry for your loss. So everybody in health care now learns how to apologize the right way according to all the training that's going on out there. So everybody that ends up having an error is going to hear the same thing. And they're going to hear it over and over again by people in health care the same way. And eventually, it's going to mean nothing to them because it won't be real anymore. It will be a programed response.
就像他们需要快点把它对我说出来一样，这就是使用的短语。你知道，“我对你的损失深表遗憾”。所以现在医疗保健领域的每个人都学会了如何按照外面的所有训练以正确的方式道歉。所以每一个最终遇到医疗错误的人都会听到同样的话。他们会一遍又一遍地听到医护人员以同样的方式说。最终，这对他们来说什么意义都没有，因为它不再真实了。这将是一个程序化的反应。
And then there are some doctors who are simply never going to change. At one of the apology seminars I went to I met this doctor who told me that he's so afraid of being sued that he tries to avoid talking to his patients all together. He actually said the words, "I live in fear." Not surprisingly, he was leery of letting me record him.
然后有一些医生根本永远不会改变。在我参加的一次道歉研讨会上，我遇到一位医生，他告诉我他如此害怕被起诉，以至于他试图完全避免与病人交谈。他真的说了“我生活在恐惧中”这些话。不出所料，他很担心让我录下他的谈话。
He told me that is was one thing to role play apologizing in a seminar of your peers. It was quite another thing to say it to an actual patient. He said every doctor he knows has been sued for malpractice. He just wants to reach retirement, which is eight years away. "I hope I make it," he said. He's terrified of saying something that will land him in court, no matter what his insurance company tells him, no matter what laws protect him. So he just tries to say nothing at all.
他告诉我，在同行研讨会上进行道歉角色扮演是一回事，对真正的病人说出来又是另一回事。他说他认识的每一个医生都被起诉过医疗事故。他只想熬到退休，还有八年时间。“我希望我能熬过去，”他说。他非常害怕说出任何会让他上法庭的话，无论他的保险公司告诉他什么，无论什么法律保护他。所以他只是试着什么都不说。
Starlee Kine in New York.
斯塔丽·凯恩，在纽约。
Well, our program was produced today by Diane Cook and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Wendy Dorr, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Amy O'Leary.
好吧，我们的节目今天由黛安·库克（Diane Cook）和我自己制作，还有亚历克斯·布伦伯格（Alex Blumberg）、温迪·多尔（Wendy Dorr）、简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）、莎拉·柯尼希（Sarah Koenig）和丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）。我们的资深制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister）管理我们的网站。制作协助来自托德·巴赫曼（Todd Bachmann）和艾米·奥利里（Amy O'Leary）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
The Apology Line story that was act two of our show today is on our first greatest hits CD from Rhino Records. Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our programs for absolutely free, or buy CDs of them.
作为今天节目第二幕的“道歉热线”故事在我们犀牛唱片公司（Rhino Records）发行的第一张精选集CD上。我们的网站是 www.thisamericanlife.org，你可以在那里免费收听我们的节目，或购买它们的CD。
Well, you know you can download audio of our program at audible.com/thisamericanlife. They have public radio programs, bestselling books, even the New York Times all at audible.com.
嗯，你知道你可以在 audible.com/thisamericanlife 下载我们节目的音频。他们有公共广播节目、畅销书，甚至《纽约时报》，都在 audible.com。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Torey Malatia, who has something that he wants to share with everybody. Something he wants to say. Torey?
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）负责，他有一些想要和大家分享的事情。他有一些想要说的话。托里？
I'm sorry for harassing the Republican officials.
我很抱歉骚扰了共和党官员。
Good you got that off your chest. I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of this American life.
很高兴你把它说出来了。我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带回更多关于这个美国生活的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台（PRI）。